today's episode you guys know him he
does the booking here he is uh he's also
a rising actor in the Hollywood scene
he's got so much energy he's one of a
kind
and we're so happy to have him here and
how we met him is absolutely fascinating
and came at me and came to be in his
life
I mean it's just it's here he is ladies
and gentlemen from the new movie MA
which comes out tomorrow thank you Nick
is in here which comes out tomorrow our
friend mr. Gianni Paola
[Music]
all right here we go sitting here with
this guy oh honey what's up man I'm
sewing how are you I'm good I'm good man
how are you today I'm good it's kind of
weird because we set everything up and
we usually like get everything together
and then I just gotta sit over there and
yep chill and it's weird being in the
seat yeah man it's weird having you in
the seat man it's exciting I know you
are so for some of our listeners that
don't know Gianni is a an actor and
Gianni it just hit up the podcast like
maybe what a year ago and just said hey
man I like the podcast yeah I think
he'll melt through burn like right oh
that's right
so I filmed the movie in Mississippi
kind of where Theo like grew up a little
bit yeah and um and then I just
remembered talking cuz I always talk
about comedy like I love it
yes listening the podcast onset like
while before like I would go and fill my
scenes I'd be listen to this past
weekend and one of the PAS came up to me
my friend Jeremy knocked on the door
he's like are you Santa Theo and I was
again like I love Theo and he's like oh
like burned like the guys that Smoots
down there like they all know Theo and I
was like really so we filmed the movie
whatever and then afterwards like um and
no knows who burn is yeah burn is the
drummer in a bishop gun whose dad I used
to work on his farm in the summertime up
in Mississippi so so he was working as a
PA or as a transport or something on the
movie that you film track in in
Mississippi yeah and then so you ran
into one of his buddies and he's like Oh
burn knows him yeah and then that's how
it all came to pass yeah and then I was
like I'd love to help you know help the
podcast I love that listen to it you
know and you know I do social media
stuff so that's kind of how we all
linked up and then yeah the rest is
history that's it been together for a
year and a year dude and so first I want
to talk about the movie so the movie is
Octavio Spencer is the lead of the movie
yes is that a safe term yeah okay she's
like the main lead okay and so and so
the movie is called MA and it comes out
May 31st so this is gonna air May 30th
so tomorrow it comes out okay
yeah Wow so the movie comes out tomorrow
and
several click so we got a bunch of white
kids going to drink in a black woman's
basement right correct basically yeah
okay yeah we have one one there's
another african-american with us okay so
and is there any like is any of the
movies that I go is there racial stuff
in the movie or not really so much um
towards the end there's like you will
see it in the trailer or it does touch
on it a little bit but it's not right it
really has nothing to do with like the
film in that sense like it's just more
like yeah like a black woman can be a
serial killer too you know what I mean
oh really yeah you just give away the
whole movie no no I'm just saying like
like it's possible for a black woman to
be like a villain Ryan I didn't mean she
says oh I see what you're saying oh yeah
I guess that's true hon they don't have
like a lot well I guess you've been just
growing up they didn't have like a lot
of black characters in in a lot of
movies I'm trying to think of like a
black villain that they had Grayskull
member that got from he-man well see
what I find interesting is like I like
would look in the internet and people
like would get upset that they'd be like
well why is the african-american the
villain like no that's like the total
opposite of like what Octavia wants like
she wants to be the villain yeah she
wants to everyone can play every role
like there's not like she doesn't have
to play a nurse or a maid in every movie
right of course yeah and there's always
black like there's this thing out there
that's just black anger like any time a
black person like oh but like breathe
somebody's like oh what are they after
Burt you know yeah like a black person's
like oh they have to breathe in the same
planet as white people you know so
sometimes you just get that black anger
out there was it intimidating cuz your
first like lead so so you're one of the
what do you play in the film I saw I
played Chaz he is a it's one of the
teens where we party with Octavia and
it's just like a high school kid there's
five of us and yeah and we meet Octavia
and she starts buying us booze and
alcohol or is it real booze when you're
on the move no it's just water oh yeah
so would think if they pretend to be
drunk yeah you have to like like also
there's also a scene there's a clip of
it in on the Instagram um where I like
drink the water and I go uh-huh and I'm
like it's just literally water but you
have to like I guess play it as if it
was yeah but the worst part was the
[ __ ] joints like because I
smoked the whole movie and pretty much
every scene and I'm smoking the joints
and it's like fake tobacco oh so you're
like I'm waking up my lungs are fried
because I'm smoking it for like four
hours
right you still smoke yeah but it's not
even real tobacco would you rather have
been just regular tobacco I would have
rather it have been like maybe like like
like vape juice or like something like
that like not because they would roll
joints like that like I would rather
have just vape the whole movie instead
of like just legitly cuz you're still
smoking like the spliffs is that what
they call them like the horse legs boy
yeah boy
of course Yanni's name is Chaz in the
movie
Swink name ever all my names have been
Brayden and Power Chaz
Brian forgot there was rated in Chaz yes
dude those are such so I feel like those
are like white slave trouble dude no I'm
sorry
do you just ripping Jionni my name is
Gianni Paolo
sure it is you don't have an identity
boy your name is Randall yeah and you're
rushing a fraternity um so you get put
into a lot of roles I know you've said
this and so also so just to clarify so
also Johnny's done all the book and
Johnny came on has done all the booking
for almost all the guests that we've had
really or reached out to him I've gotten
a couple hitters but yeah for the most
part for the most part you guys helped a
lot now you got a good thing going yeah
I know you guys have been great man you
guys put up with me a lot of times which
I know isn't easy especially over text
message and name five guests that we've
tried to get that we haven't got that
people love that they really want Danny
McBride okay I've tried a lot recently
Chris Pratt he's busy I'm just trying to
think of like the ones more recent like
Anna Faris like people who also have
podcasts Dax Shepard like those are the
people who I have reached out to just
because they're kind of in that world
and it's realistic okay I like to boo
see little blue blue sea lil boosie we
got him yeah we tried pretty much in the
group everyone who's been like we really
want him I'm like I tried him three
months ago I tried him last week Amanda
knocks Amanda knocks we tried her a lot
so yeah we try like we Norman
we should kill a roommate that will get
her in here sorry I did that's best uh
and that's a joke if anybody's roommates
ever died yeah um so we found almost
dead not like are we strategic about it
what's it like to reach out to somebody
and and could you do that you know it's
like what's that like um I don't mind it
just because it's publicist so it's like
they're people like I don't have Chris
Pratt's email you're right I don't like
to but it's Chris Pratt at gmail yeah so
I just read that the publicist and I'm
like listen well see I was talking to
Nick about this before you came in
uh-huh it kind of upsets me the whole
like what's going on now because a lot
of people to go and promote movies
they're going on Kimmel they're going on
like like weird cable like cooking shows
and it to promote things the generic way
that it's always been done right and
that's not the way people are listening
anymore right they don't get the views
anymore it's podcast that's Joe Rogan
it's you it's Tiger belly like those are
the ones that that's what's getting the
listens from the Millennials and that's
what this movies about which is why I've
been going on podcast to promote yeah I
mean I wouldn't go on Kimmel anyway just
because I'm not big enough but like this
is it this is like what the studio's
have to realize like this is where
people are gonna you know go to and it's
a full-length thing yeah like if they're
listening to a clip on Jimmy Kimmel and
they're talking about Zac Efron
you know his dick came out in a movie
scene or something like that who was on
a plane with Miki Austin he walked by
three times dude dude I love him I mean
like in like a straight way yep son of
return he was all tired when he was
welcomed by every time really yeah it
was he in first class with it was like
it can't be that tired and walking in
all three times it's a yawning and
stretch yeah like he'd be like seven
fake yawns like it was almost a
cheerleader by the end of it where is he
coming from like where was this when he
went to New York to New York yeah but so
is it did you send yourself an email to
get booked on here then yeah I did I
sent myself a confirmation yeah we got a
reply yeah yeah weeks without a reply
who was the one that gee honey we missed
him because Jionni dropped the ball who
was it Callen yeah but I didn't drop the
ball it was Bryan Callen yeah because he
pretended he never had the ball
knew Brian knew that he was coming on
this past weekend but it conflicted with
Rogen yeah so like they're right across
the wall so I assume they're gonna do
their episode and then just come he's
gonna walk in here after cuz I confirm
with him like a week before this yeah
and then he went on Rogan sit was like
oh you forgot you forgot about deal but
you went on Rogan okay yeah I think if
you hear the word Rogan just forget
about everything I don't I don't blame
them it's like I'm gonna rogue I'm gonna
go to Danny so here leg CPD
that's mint-flavored yeah shout all
incoming Apothecary well do first of all
just want to say thanks so much man and
second of all yeah it's crazy it's
almost like we backdoored ourselves into
a guest with Jionni you know so yeah I
worked for 52 weeks just to get on this
podcast for free with one me undies a
month okay got one pair they're supposed
to sing you which I'm wearing right now
are you really oh wow yeah there's a
good one yeah I'm telling you I've I
really adapted to these mediums he's not
they're not showing up for Gianni yeah
dude I didn't get my may [ __ ] thing
you know your water mediums yeah you
know what happened some of these boxes
but we definitely should get you some
more pairs so we uh when you're shooting
the film like how long does it take to
shoot to shoot a movie like for somebody
who doesn't know like me this took about
um I'd say four weeks and then we net it
yeah and then we because it's a Blum
House film so they do like smaller
budgets you know not as you know big and
crazy as like the action movies those
probably take like three four months
right um yeah this was about four weeks
but then we did go back and do reshoots
because they wanted to you know fix him
stuff at the end yeah so total about
five weeks five and half weeks and was
that the most the first time he'd ever
spent really a lot of time in
Mississippi yeah it was the first time I
had ever been in Mississippi and I loved
it yeah like honestly like I would
consider getting out there because I
loved it that much Wow yeah and do you
so now when you're on these sets they
look like get some ladies in there in
the film - were you guys like is there a
lot of like chicanery going on behind
the scenes like a lot of like you know
you know people you know meeting up at
night is it pretty low-key
well we'd uh since this was such a
smaller budget like you're filming like
for 13 14 hours a day so you like don't
have time like you like that whole day
is to film and like you got to be up in
the morning and get get going again but
I don't smoke or drink as you know so
like that's not my thing like people
would go out to bars and stuff to party
that night I'd go right to bed make sure
I was off book for the next day I'd wake
up at 5 a.m. I had a personal trainer
because I had to get naked in the movie
so I had a personal trainer I had to
were you just did in every scene that
seems like something Jionni would do
yeah are you sure you don't want to take
your clothes ever like dude you're in
math class okay keep your [ __ ]
clothes on like all these books are
heavy yeah it sounds like a young Jocko
willing he's just getting everybody's
going out to parties waking up at 4:30
training yes I rent I ran around
Mississippi like like I would run the
hills of Mississippi there's a hill you
know where the Magnolia Bluffs Casino is
yeah that big hill that goes up to where
the hotel is I would run that every
morning like 435 G and then I would go
to my personal trainer and lift man
that's crazy yeah and what would you do
then paint yourself green and just
attack people it's like you're very
Incredible Hulk it what do you think
about Mississippi like what was your
some of your first thoughts whenever you
were there so day two so we went to the
hotel and we like kind of went around
the the town a little bit for the first
you know this isn't Natchez this is the
Natchez correct we stated the magnolia
blossom tell for a couple weeks so we
walked around there and I thought it was
incredible like we went to this place
called the pink pig the barbeque play
yeah been there so good I just like you
know cotton cotton alley cafe like a lot
of the places were momma's did you go to
that fat mom is a tamale place yeah we
went there and I like I literally loved
it like I can't stress enough how much I
love Mississippi but day - yeah we're
filming we go to - we go to set we're
filming outside a liquor store and it's
in a pretty seedy area like where the
liquor store is and there is an urban
gentleman as you would say oh yeah he
comes out of his house and he starts
like like he's probably [ __ ] up on
something and he's like yelling like you
want a filmer no [ __ ] movie in front
of my house like getting like aggressive
and then like a bunch of more as a cat
will
it was Pat Williams yeah he wanted to be
in the movie but he never roll for him
really if someone was getting aggressive
he has someone did get aggressive but
that was kind of the only like negative
experience and it's not even that
negative it's just some guy that was
yelling at us that was probably [ __ ]
up yeah but I did love it like the
people there were so nice I specifically
remember going to Mississippi and then I
would like if we go to the markets on
the weekends I'd be leaving and I'd be
like like like to the people with their
cars full of stuff like thanks everyone
have a good weekend and everyone big oh
thank you so much man yeah and then the
next day I could like when I came back
to LA I went to the Whole Foods and I
went to turn I was like have a good week
and everyone everyone's like yeah get
out yeah you're the [ __ ] is this idiot
yeah Logan Paul was any earlier who the
[ __ ] are you yeah yeah yeah there is
something different it's just like
there's more value on just like but do
you think that that kind of stuff is
real sometimes I wonder if it's like
genuine or if there's just that people
there's more time for people to spend
with each other so they even enjoy the
smaller things like even waving goodbye
to someone in Mississippi or Saint yeah
or just like in yeah in slower parts of
the country Mississippi is probably in
some ways that from the places I've been
one of the so like it's gets really slow
there you know I'm like if you pick up a
seashell off the ground you can
definitely hear slaves in the back and
deal in it like it's old-school you
understand like I still have there's
Civil War reenactments in the back of
every like Chevron there's like you know
what I'm saying it has like right behind
a [ __ ] show nice oh dude it's very
yeah they got a show knees right there I
went there on Thanksgiving actually
really yeah some lady burned her hand in
the cobbler I remember and they had to
call the paramedics but but yeah it has
an old-school vibe doesn't it it does
I'll never say I think people are like
brought up with those values in
Mississippi yeah and not so much LA
because no one really gives a [ __ ] about
anyone else but themselves in LA yeah
like in Mississippi like there's really
like not much more to do right--so
values and stuff like that are important
yeah oh it's interesting man yeah that's
so crazy you got to be down there
because I mean who else even gets to go
there nobody even everything things to
go to Natchez because it used to be like
a major stop on like for the gambling
boats and all of that yeah
you know it was incredible like I truly
think that was like one of my best
experiences of my life so far
I love that now the nights where you do
get a little lonely out there because I
know if you're working out hard in the
morning you're sweating all day and
you're you know I mean you're like a
rock star you shooting a movie in a
small town you know you have somebody
with a walkie-talkie walking around with
you you know I know what it's like you
know to at least have you know you get
that you know you get a little bit of
pop right yeah when you get on a tinder
and a place like Mississippi you get on
the Bumble or [ __ ] anything cuz
you're out in the rural sticks here at
that point they should have [ __ ]
for rural areas yeah [ __ ] for
anybody who's trying to get laid outside
of the city it's like that um did you
say if you have if you open those amps
up what's it like out there I I didn't
you didn't my Instagram was popping
pretty like in the requests but um like
I'm gonna be like honest like this is
was a I think it was around the time
where all the me to stuff happened oh
yeah yeah and it was like people were
just getting trouble like doing stuff on
movie sets like and I was just like
listen I'm not even gonna put myself in
that position like to even like be with
a girl alone like who was an extra in
the film or something like that like
this is like my chance like I'm not
gonna like worry about a girl like and
I'm not gonna get myself in trouble in
any way yeah so I stay away from it
that's awesome yeah I was pretty like
dedicated for these like four weeks like
so actually you know what I did so I got
a I got a porn hub or a browsers account
Wow yeah go and hide yeah I got of
Reiser's account I don't think it's 4G
and some of their LT in some of those
areas over there I don't even know but
it was so funny because I checked on my
account like three why my credit card
same like three months later and it
billed me for like a year Horse like
like the month before so I called them
and it didn't say browsers it said like
CTE billing or something yeah and I
called and I was like hey guys like why
like why quote what is this charge for I
didn't let's go to that call right yeah
we had a call oh yeah it's just just odd
guys discussing never press expenses but
I had it on speakerphone and I was with
one of my like buddies who's like not
super close but like he's close and I
had an on speaker in my living room and
I was like what
like what's his charge like I didn't do
this because I was just trying to figure
out my finances and he's like oh did you
sign up for a brazzers in Natchez
Mississippi I was like yeah that was me
dude it must have been pretty cool
though like being so Octavia obviously
African American black woman to be a
lead on a movie of Mississippi we're
probably a hundred years earlier you
know like people in those here like
especially like you know people with her
skin color will probably having a much
tougher you know or a tougher time they
still doing a lot especially like in
some rural parts of of that state you
know easy Anas yeah in Louisiana yeah it
must've been pretty cool kind of yeah it
actually isn't like I did not think of
that that's it is pretty incredible like
she's leading a studio film yeah and
it's her yeah did she comment on
anything like that like not like you
know not an any sort of net you know
negative way but did she like I wonder
if she even noticed that yeah not that I
can remember yeah I don't know but I
mean it's definitely like incredible
like honestly because on power like the
showrunner for me is a black woman -
yeah so like that's a show that I'm on
like for a long period of time and I'm
doing this movie and like the lead -
black woman so it's kind of cool like
everything that I'm doing are led by
black women you know I mean which is
like it's awesome it's a great time for
that you know yeah yeah it is definitely
a time where it's like you gotta have
more like yay especially now is like
America gets more like more diverse and
it wasn't we were kids to have more
people like putting their influence on
things you know she can get different
perspectives and stuff so if what's
another type of movie that I would say
and then I would be like oh then you'll
like MA it's it's kind of similar like
it's like Halloween kind of it's a
little bit like it kind of has elements
of that but it's I would say it's more
psychological so it's like I would say
it's like get out and screamish like
American Pie combined like it's Oh like
I'm telling you it's a lot of fun it's a
really [ __ ] fun movie like if you're
in college or high school or like young
like that that audience like they're
gonna [ __ ] love this because it's
just like crazy it's like a party movie
and then it turns turns deadly it's good
well yeah is there any breaks in where
you can make out with somebody or not or
is it pretty I do make out with someone
in it really no I'm talking about if
you're in the theater yeah I could you
like a scene or two where you [ __ ]
you could just kind of doze off a little
bit I remember Dada yeah trying to get
that over there over the pants [ __ ]
you know you get all of it nothing gets
me going like Octavia Spencer stabbing
somebody burning Gianni with an iron
yeah
nothing history got fired up like seeing
a white freshman getting burned with an
iron in the erection section fear is
nature's most powerful aphrodisiac
oh yeah you know what they say when a
planes going down 90% of the men in
their right
that's crazy oh is that like is that a
real thing yeah a statistic and you
already get airplane boner so you even
imagine do you know so do you have one
right now bro no I don't but so much so
that I get them that people [ __ ]
complain about it that's how much I get
dude that's all that's so exciting so uh
so how do you start so you're gonna be
in a film like what are you how do you
try to like like what are your
expectations of like what your career is
gonna be like after this how do you
manage those expectations like what do
you start to think about because this is
like I mean well people you know watch
power you know that's a popular show but
this will be you know this is like a
film so what is like your brain go there
like what does your brain have you like
in like a hot tub in two weeks and Aspen
like I'm just trying to think because
you have a young brain you know yeah I
got an old brain that's like oh dude
you'll be definitely still working for
us in a month yeah he's like we're gonna
drop him like a bad yeah um I actually
the total opposite like I hope this
launches me into to something like that
I can consistently work on a show for
like four years but like I don't want to
leave the podcast like if something were
to have to like shoot away like I would
still find a way to like promote lis
book yes and like work with you guys cuz
this is like the most fun part of like
my job like the reason why I am an actor
is because like I like to have fun like
I like to show up on set I like to like
joke around and like you know it's it's
fun you've been on sets yeah you're
always in a good mood man I wish I was
in a good mood as much as you do well
maybe one day we'll do a movie and you
can now lead it you know I love that I
really would like and that's just
something like that I like doing like
this has been like incredible for me
I've learned so much from you and Nick I
so much about the podcasting world and
like other people yeah like like
honestly like after this movie comes out
I'm hoping that I get a TV series for a
long period of time it films in LA and I
have you know like a couple hours a day
free where I can podcast and come in and
like do this I could be [ __ ] awesome
Nick do you think once Johnny starts to
pop off a little bit you know he starts
behind jewelry and stuff like that dude
buying his brother like fancy necklaces
and stuff you think he'll still come in
with us or no I got I got to believe the
little guy he's really yeah I think I
think he truly loves this like he said
he loves comedy he was listening before
he worked with us so like being around
it I see him squealing his tires outside
of the studio what we're trying to
record ya know and we're getting a new
studio like I'm so excited about that
that's true man this is our last guest
in this studio so it's actually fitting
since you've booked so many of them to
come in and close it out yeah I think I
started right when you guys moved in
here like I think my first day like you
had had one guest in here I think was
Jay Mohr and I wasn't there for that
yeah that's crazy man I think of all the
guests that have come through here you
know yeah that's like 120 episodes since
he's been here yeah that's crazy then
yeah I can't even I can't even fatter
than that it's been fun we should do
like one of those um those graduation
videos where it's like Dan and then and
it like cuts to all the guests yeah and
he gets older yeah he never looks any
older because he still looks 14 what's
the youngest you can go read for in a
film honestly and legitimately play I
read for 15 like maybe three months ago
now do you take supplements and stuff to
keep your hormones down or keep your
hormones at bay no I do not really yeah
oh wow yeah I don't I guess I look yeah
I look a little young I could see was
like a year like Abe Lincoln's like
young son who's like leaving the family
to go play rugby you know third like you
smell sell snake oil on [ __ ]
Hollywood Bowl oh I do look like [ __ ]
okay somebody that gets shot in one of
the oh I look like somebody who's
looking for something by a stream and
Red Dead Redemption
you know you look like Paul Ruben and
Ruben Studdard like this joke it was
Ruben Studdard no he didn't you saw that
on stage no I never told anybody
God there look dude here's another 14
year old boy who's just a silver son
that's my cast mate Corrie Fogle man
asan on the movie is it yeah he told me
he sent in a video
this gives like a teen heartthrob he's
got like 3 million followers he's really
a focal Manas yeah he was a so you know
Boy Meets World
yeah they did a reboot and he was the
lead of Girl Meets World
oh wow with Topanga Miller correct or
did Topanga Canyon or what is her name
Topanga danielle fishel ZL name she
black she blocked me on Twitter actually
the whole cast of Boy Meets World did
cuz I I had this friend who had tweeted
them constantly like they were actually
their characters and I I jumped in on
hilarious it's like when are you Cory am
I not surprised Nick is blocked by a
bunch of teens dude first of all good
probably great if you blocked my teens
in it and I can't remember the dads name
but he blocked the - I love him we're
all in court a year from now for Nick
didn't use this and they're just
flashing to all the teams that have
octave Daniel oppa shell is a full-grown
adult know what she's like though is she
cool or not I wonder I met the guy Corey
I heard she was a little crazy I could
see her being nuts yeah I met the guy
Corey from the first season it was super
cool not Corey who's this friend Ben
Savage rider rider strong oh yeah season
yeah he was really really cool guy Ben
Savage is brother Fred Savage he's like
a he's like a director like he's killing
it he's a workhorse he does commercials
he does he does fulling feature he was
on that uh that Netflix show um what was
the one with other years no no with Nat
Faxon and keegan-michael key
oh yeah know what when he was on that
one sounds Billy Eichner he's pretty
good the guy was it up I look at about
this video let's hear mr. Poe let's see
what's young man's name again
Corey Fogle Mannix Corey Fogle man I see
how last name hey bro bro Jionni its
Corey here I just first want to say I'm
so excited for Mama I think it looks
you look so great in it
we got so my question for you is Huttese
who is your most famous friend that rake
well right he wants me to say him of
course but you know who I'm gonna say is
50 [ __ ] cent it's so I'm gonna say
really yeah I wouldn't say he's my
friend but I always think about this
most of the question dude otherwise
you're just saying who's the most famous
person you can think of right now
Mori focal Manas dude this guy really
likes you Gianni
yeah we're well we became good friends
on the movie like he's an awesome kid
when they were hanging out more around
the movie to watch Jionni's Instagram
stories and Jionni's like he just
bothers Cory on his Instagram it was
pretty entertaining because we go to
like like it's pretty crazy you go to a
Walmart in Mississippi hmm and none of
these people are expecting you know like
anyone to be there right so like Cory
would walk in in like a family would be
crying so much and like I'm sitting
there like recording it cuz I think it's
awesome like yeah he's like dude stop
and he gets like really like
embarrassing like it's all so funny like
like you see like like Octavia and like
like I stayed for Thanksgiving at Tate's
house so like Jessica Chastain was there
and that the director of the movie Tate
Taylor and so I stayed for Thanksgiving
and they would go to Walmart like all of
them and it's like you're all a listers
like you know weird like town and
Mississippi like no one expects us you
know yeah so I always think that's like
wild to me you know I'm gonna that
Walley world over there
the big one the big one yes and it's
nice I mean it's it's good it's good
they got a McDonald's in the back yeah
but the director Tate loves you really
and the producer Jon yeah he's like
great director he directed the help he
directed get on up the James Bond movie
now you're making me feel like I should
have done that cuz I went and met that
guy Lee Daniels recently Harvey Lee
Oswald yeah Lee Daniels huh yeah Lee
Daniels RV RV Oswald that God they did
the movie the butler and they got that
does that show
Empire okay so little justice Millette
yeah just a smile let country and he
gave me a role in the room really for
what your chest on is some new pilot
that Whitney's doing mmm-hmm yeah he
said he's like he's like who's that guy
like that comedian on your Instagram
like he's hilarious we love him so it's
like there does he prefer men or women
this guy well he is married to the
producer of the movie he's a loser what
but he was a man okay but it's also
super cuz I didn't game in in
Mississippi or a different lot but it's
so weird because they're all there
pretty much beautiful women yeah they're
like the mayor of love if you're a gay
man in Mississippi you're the mayor of
wherever you are yeah yeah exactly yeah
like when we went on for Thanksgiving he
like left in the car and he like he went
Mississippi has no rules he has like
this white Cadillac with with like no
rules if you're why like this Cadillac
and it's like he's got in a fedora and
he's buying guns and shrimp and alcohol
and cocaine and he's just driving down
the things like this this gay man with a
fedora and a white Cadillac no roof on
it it's just like hilarious that sounds
like a casserole he's making yeah you
put a little propane and some shrimp in
a bucket and [ __ ] shoot it four times
voila baby wow that's dynamite shrimp
you know that's awesome man that's so
cool you got to go there and just spend
time and it's such like it feels almost
like when I go to Mississippi a lot of
times and so especially in Natchez then
I'm traveling to the past yeah but
you're like another time I would I would
love to go back that's why I thought you
were gonna go to that festival this
weekend with Michigan is it well it's
yeah weekend's again two weekends ago
but I would have went cuz I yeah we saw
the live feed today's episode is brought
to you by Ridge wallet Ridge wallet
they've done a lot of great things here
and been a longtime supporter of this
past weekend and I'll see a lot of guys
on the road when I'm out there and about
and they'll show me they got that f-p
see that front pocket carry because
Ridge wallet they've redesigned the way
you carry that money the way you carry
them meal tickets used to be you had
that little saddle
back on your back pocket that heavy
piece of cow skin but now you get that
hard hitter that front pocket carry
ridge while it'll block possibly a
bullet I wouldn't try it but it could
and right now you can go to Ridge wallet
comm slash hitter and use code hitter at
checkout for 10%
that's code a chai tter for 10% off at
Ridge wallet dot-com slash hitter I've
had different wallets and I don't have
them anymore and I don't know what else
I can say about that except you know
that if you tired of being in the valley
of wallet uncomfort then head up over
that Ridge this past weekend is
gratefully brought to you by skills
share skills share it's an online
learning community for creators with
more than 25,000 classes in design
business and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and career you can take
classes in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration things that are very useful
these days in today's modern world you
can you don't have a skill you can learn
it skills share whether you're looking
to discover new passions start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
skills share is there to help you keep
learning join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of skill share
for free that's right skill share is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von again go
to Skillshare comm slash Theo von to
start your two months now
that's Skillshare comm slash Theo von
go get those skills um Nick how's it
been cuz you work with Johnny sometimes
cuz he's hearing mills around he loiters
something to call it how's that been for
you I feel like uh it's it's dope to be
honest so I we rip on each other but
he's super fun to have around
he's always in a good mood I'm working
here by myself a lot so like his energy
like it's great obviously he's great to
be around and I'm just like super
impressed by it because we haven't said
yeah he's 22 oh yeah that's true I think
and like I don't know he's a workhorse
and he's like very strategic and like
what he's doing like I don't know I I
see bright things for the kid yeah man I
feel you dude yeah it is really exciting
bro you know you like you can yeah
especially since you get to see like
what the podcast world is like and then
also see like what the Hollywood world
is like it's like yeah you'll be able to
probably learn enough to kind of head
you will hedge one against the other at
certain points you know to probably if
you wanted to produce your own thing or
make your own film that you wanted a
star in it's like you knew you know it's
like you know where you can find an
audience for it if it's something that's
good which I think a lot of it is going
like it's going away from Hollywood and
it's going more towards like its you in
your hands you know I mean because that
like I'm writing in and trying to you
know develop my own show and you know
like that's the way the way it's going
you know I mean you don't need Hollywood
as much as you used to yeah yeah it's
like you can really make your own
Hollywood condo yeah you know I mean you
gotta have I just I can't see how it's
not gonna go more that direction there's
so many different outlets now like these
other streaming services are getting
like more money behind them like I mean
this is sports obviously but like that
does own channel like it's the it's now
on par with the quality of content that
like ESPN streaming service is putting
out and it came out of nowhere when they
call ad is owned it spelled Daz and
honestly that's their biggest problem is
the branding yeah like they sank Canelo
for like 300 million they got money
behind him right it's only edgy but
these things are springing up all over
so there's if you put out good content
you're gonna find a place and someone
who's gonna give you money to produce it
and it doesn't have to be through the
traditional channels because it's almost
like like me undies doesn't go to a
store anymore they go directly to the
people and that's what the content
creators are doing
yeah what's weird cuz it's also like the
whole like louis c.k like he just
doesn't even need any networks he just
has his own website and people go and
and listen to his special you know ii
mean so it's like he doesn't need
netflix to buy a special he can just put
it on
so well the first one he did but then
after that he went back to net he went
back to I think he did he sell it sell
the one that was already up on his thing
back to them not sure that's a good
question because then he may double the
amount of money you know I mean he sold
it to everyone and then was like okay I
made all my money no one's buying it
anymore
I'll sell to Netflix people will still
watch it we'll get exposure and I'll
make money right and if you would have
we might have said this on the podcast
before but if he would have had like a
podcast during the whole time he could
have even not went away and like still
had like this groundswell of people in
his corner that like like I don't know
like yeah he did something wrong but
we're not gonna just drop him completely
instead of going dormant or whatever for
the last year and a half yeah yeah it's
kind of interesting to like you know
it's kind of interesting and it's kind
of like scary to think about like yeah
like what you know like what's gonna be
next how it's gonna change how we're
like though you know how are because so
many people listen and watch podcasts
and go to more than cable now yeah and
go to see those entertainers you know in
the and that those are the entertainers
that people go out to see yeah it's just
kind of like it kind of like doesn't
plague me sometimes but it just has me
thinking like well what are the
possibilities of like creating our own
you know network makes yeah and then
just getting advertisers attached so
that we don't have you know notes and it
can just be straight out of our own
brain exactly well I'm super excited
about your special because I mean I
don't know if I mean most of you guys
are probably seeing deal on the road but
dude you're [ __ ] our is incredible
it's like it's like the best hour I
think I have seen maybe ever and you're
no offense like that was great but like
this is a whole new level
like Sarah III agree cuz like a so
edible re man is he follows you on the
road he opens for you he sends me the
footage and sometimes there's whole
shows on there and I'm trying to find
like interesting parts so like I'm
listening to I'm like two times or three
times speed but like you listen to it
and it's like it's like music you can
just all of a sudden there's laughter
Theo says something there's laughter and
it's just this constant wave it's it's
where it's crazy like how it's boom boom
boom boom well every time you like cuz I
have your email
computer because you know we book guess
and every time like like a clip from
like the ice house will come in I'll be
like oh [ __ ] like I don't know if I can
listen to this like I just like I think
I truly that's how I first like knew of
you yeah I went to the Comedy Store one
night to watch D'Elia and Sebastian and
I think you had a later spot cuz at this
time you like weren't as big as you were
then this is maybe two and a half years
ago yeah you had like an 11:30 spot and
I was gonna leave and then you came on
and I was sat in the front row and like
everyone around me had already gone and
I was like who the [ __ ] is this guy like
this is the most unique like interesting
it was just so different to me and I was
laughing my ass off and that's how I
just knew of you and then I started like
I went to a couple of years shows and I
started listening to podcasts and then
you know it's crazy Here I am you know
yeah here we are I mean ah well thank
you it's nice you guys to say man I know
that I've been hard to deal with all
that sometimes over the years has been
tough man for me she's been you know
it's been fun to have a lot more work
and stuff but it's been it's been such
like a level of like just stress I think
in fear you know like working like so
long in an industry and like you know
not you know not really getting much
traction and then all once and then like
yet getting a lot of traction but also
like it's your own traction kind of that
you know that we've created here with
the podcast yeah and you know not alone
but with is so it's just like kind of
scary it's like and then suddenly
everybody wants to come and like get you
to do stuff and you're like well what do
I do am I making good choices and I'm
making bad choices well when I first
started working here a year ago you had
I think it was 68 thousand followers on
Instagram you have 800,000 now like that
is incredible you don't I mean like and
that's all through the podcast and
comedy you have it it's not like you did
a [ __ ] studio movie you don't mean
it's not like you're on a TV show that
is all through comedy and podcasts yeah
which is what people need to understand
like that
it's the podcast world which is like and
social media through Instagram like
that's what's blowing people up you
don't I mean yeah like you can you did
that without Hollywood yeah well you can
get your voice out there well I mean I
had a lot of help I mean Nick's done a
great job you know I mean
has done a great job and even like you
know moments today like this morning you
know sometimes I'll wake up there's two
ways I'll wake up a good way and then
the other way I'll wake up and I'm a
[ __ ] loser but I can tell where every
new text me what it is so crazy how you
can tell via and attacks like if I can
feel the energy yeah yeah look there's
energy that goes into the screen glad
some of its coming up when he wakes up
it's either like hey man good morning
like ready to get today going like all
this stuff like do we have everyone good
and then it's also like hey man what the
[ __ ] is going on why the [ __ ] is a
studio not at 68 degrees yeah broke the
thermostat you think this [ __ ] two
plants can survive in there I'm thinking
about yourself G through the new studio
we got windows do we're gonna have a
[ __ ] forest dude yeah you guys don't
even know we'll put some of the footage
in we'll put some of the footage on to
the patreon yeah was Jionni just started
helping out like kind of get or trying
to get to our patreon or like a better
level where you guys can see some of the
behind the scenes stuff that we do
better and we'll put like those videos
of when everyone over to the new studio
and checked it out yeah it's kind of
crazy it there's definitely more room
there's gonna be just a place where you
can put stuff what are you looking
forward to Nick cuz you're in the studio
most of the time yeah I mean if we I
think we could find talent and kind of
it's gonna be hard to get any show to
the level of this cuz you're a unique
you unique talent but I think we could
find people who we think have potential
that aren't seen and produce their own
pods and and recreate kind of the
formula we have like the clips Channel
and the instagrams that help blow them
up and then with our connections the
other pod get them put out and I think
we could we could have our own network I
mean your mom's house is doing it yeah
no reason we can't yeah I want to do
like our own them yeah we should still
dr. Gruber man he's so good our own
potential potential like production
company like onward productions and yeah
do our own [ __ ] in-house you don't need
to go to some sketchy thing we sell our
own ads it's like it's it's all together
and it's like a collaborative creative
experience you know it's not like you
have to deal with some guy in a [ __ ]
suit telling you you're not funny enough
or you're like well what have you ever
done you know what I mean yeah yeah no
look man I mean it would definitely be
neat you know I think my
fears are just you know doing too much
other stuff SATA can't do stand up that
much yeah I don't do it but I I do think
it's like use your umbrella though like
you don't necessarily pile on you more
stuff but it's like use your umbrella
yeah to put on other stuff like you
start you start growing like you're just
branches off and it doesn't always have
to be you you like when we have someone
with a show you're their first guest and
stuff kind of help pop him off but then
we go runnin with that yeah it's like
the same thing like what Kevin Hart does
I mean he has heartbeat productions and
he does so many different shows and like
executive produces them and like
creatively you know helps him but he has
really not much to do with it it's just
kind of his name and his brand will help
get it out there using lol network to
which like an a lot a lot it's much more
yeah yeah yeah I actually interviewed
them before I was at Funny or Die and I
almost had it but I think I didn't know
it was as urban as it was and I kept
telling him like they have all this just
for laughs content they own a bunch of
that and I was like oh that's like where
you want to go and that's like nerdy
white comedy and so I think that's kind
of where I carry Seinfeld what's the big
deal watermelon have you heard of this
guy Theo from Louisiana although that's
a bad example because you you you got
that swag but yeah yeah yeah dude black
guys love you man I do yeah wish someone
would come to the shows there's been 11
that have come to the shows I think this
familiar yeah and they're always like
hey man just wanna let you know you have
some black support and one of us my
friend Stan that came to two shows I
think I tell all my friends about you
and they beat the [ __ ] out of me yeah
but dude you know what I was thinking
there's not a lot of crossover in music
there's a lot of crossover right I think
crossovers in what like like if you look
at black and white audiences that go to
see entertainment you know a lot of
there there's still a lot of like a lot
of black audience to go to see black
stuff a lot of why don't need to go to
see kind of white stuff well I think I
mean I think it bends in someplace usek
is definitely a place where it bends a
lot well I think because I like post
Malone I don't think a lot of black
people go see post Malone but like Drake
like all like black people go see Drake
and like white people go see Drake so I
think it's more
black artists that the white people love
but I feel like sometimes when it's a
white artist like there's not support
from maybe the black community is like
oh he's like he's like white like trying
to like take like what we create right
so I think like that's kind of where
Michael Rapaport yeah yeah like you know
yelling oh yeah actually if I feel
really Puck McGary ohm but he married
also a black woman I think you have to
go that far really I like Neal Brennan
he married Dave Chappelle so he married
himself a couple times you know I think
it'd be good bill burr bill burr Yemen
has a but he's got his content is so
white like I remember I was drunk
driving at the McDonald's it's like
black people like no we don't remember
that you can edit yeah he's just so
frustrated with everything is the best
yeah have you seen those two black guys
they have a YouTube channel and they'll
watch like white comic get off they've
done one on you and they just absolutely
loved it and I've seen one them doober I
want to find their names cos yeah those
guys are great yeah it is interesting I
wonder if there's like um I think it
would do thing I think it would if there
were more and maybe this will just
happen with time where more black people
support white things and not think that
it's like there because a lot of white
people aren't like support my stuff I'm
like a you know like they don't have any
there's no ego there's no racial ego on
it yeah I think there's sometimes
there's probably like you know when
you've been like a community that's been
like historically kind of like hell held
in to such a place and not had
opportunity than you probably think like
oh yeah this is our opportunity right
why are you taking this from us like we
have this you know anyway why are you
taking that to I guess it may be what
the feeling is but out here on the west
coast I see a lot more guys who were
just like it doesn't really matter I
think that is one thing you find more
and even just as time goes on I see a
lot more people it doesn't really matter
kind of well that's where I see it going
where it's like like a lot of it now is
that like I want to give diverse people
jobs like which is great like I fully
support that but it's like like I'm
hoping in like the next like 30 years
where it's just like no one gives a [ __ ]
it's equal the funniest person gets the
job yeah that's writer gets the writing
job the best actor gets an acting job
like yeah we want it to be diverse but
like it should be like that shouldn't
matter you know
should just be who's the best yeah yeah
it's been as long as everybody has the
opportunity exactly us correct you know
and also I think one thing is like you
know a lot of strike with struggle comes
without struggle you don't get any you
know you got to have some to get to have
something I think exactly you know like
you don't get a diamond without some
pressure like I think like you're gonna
see a lot more softer black athletes
over time you know as like yeah once
like great like once you realize what
it's like to grow up in an area where
you know like you have sweaters all the
time as [ __ ] like that dude you're gonna
have a good black guys that can't even
dump sorry I imagine that it's already
kind of happening Jimmy Butler when he
was on the wolves like he hated his
teammates cuz they're all like younger
Millennials and they would play video
games constantly like they're always
playing for at night and he [ __ ]
hated his teammates yeah like he's
fitting in way better in Philadelphia he
screamed at him one time at a practice
and they like it made a bunch of news
he's like you [ __ ] need me and then
he did man in a train left because Jimmy
Jimmy Butler is old school
oh he's old school yeah it's definitely
I mean it's definitely like yeah it's
gonna be I mean I do look forward to a
day where maybe there'll be an
opportunity for a white man and be able
to start on a basketball team you know
just because you know like because Larry
Bird dude but that was there one guy way
to go to Poland to find the guy they
said they found him in ice and an
iceberg thought out who's that guy do
chick or something uh for the Nugget oh
yeah the Joker
Niccolo joking he's arvydas Sabonis
reincarnate I love Nicola Nicola joke
itch yeah it's not getting bro I can
tell [ __ ] European here come the
white guy in the NBA he was top five
this year and he said he's a seven-foot
like to huge thick center in being the
guy with the ball on pick-and-rolls like
they run him at point he's a crazy catch
a sir it's sweet yeah you've had to
really go deep into Europe man deep into
like those you know like the just the
crevasse is of Europe you know to really
find like a white guy I can play
basketball we got a white guy that once
they asked Gianni a question oh this is
dead
looks like his dad bro is this your
father now let's get this video oh how
long we other what's up Gianni you sexy
little short bread about time you found
your way on the podcast boy I want to
know what it's like to be on power I
also want to know what it's like to work
with do I know that you must think that
is super funny just like we all do and I
want to know what that's like man I know
that you all must have some good times
and have much laughs so yeah and also I
don't get my chest bigger boat yeah
April's that for a young guy hold it
bang bang probably 28th Gang Gang man we
probably should do more activities as a
group you know maybe we'll have more
opportunity to do that in the studio
cause it'll be a little more room yeah
what's it like to be on power um it's
incredible and I think it's so much
cooler being on a black show then a
white show because like you show up to a
white show and everyone's just like kind
of like like when you get like the cast
and crew of like a black show and
they're laughing like at what you're
doing it feels better
oh yeah it's just like like it's the
same thing it's like when you're wearing
like an outfit and like a white guy
comes up to you and he's like don't bow
fee and you're like okay dude get the
[ __ ] away from it you had a black guys
like sick outfit you like [ __ ] yeah I
could do anything now maybe I play pro
ball yeah yeah I'm gonna go try for the
NFL maybe yes yeah like I even Pat's you
on the back or actually bumps in you in
the other why you play why is it so much
cooler I think there's just like cuz I
think you know I think for me anyway let
me think about that you know I don't
know black guys just seem more confident
and comfortable agreed so you feel like
if oh and you wish you had that for me I
wish I had that so if they like if they
think I'm that way or something then
it's PD dude yeah like a black guy with
like a disease you know what I mean it's
just I know it's just like well I I
never see it's just like they're just
like [ __ ] you know got that and they
don't talk about it you know like yeah
cool black guy was I gonna talk about
his disease yeah
like yeah I got it whatever yeah it's
cool we're ruining Jionni's career I
know all right recently but no there
look I think there's always been
something that you know like her for me
it was always something I wanted to be
accepted by the black community or make
also making any other community laugh is
also a fun thing the only community I
had around growing up in my er it was
black and white so there was any other
option yeah but yeah if you give you're
like you know you're in a group of
Latinos you make all those guys last so
so much cool yeah it's like oh [ __ ] it's
so much cooler you think I'm cool I mean
working with 50 cent is literally like a
dream like if you told me when I was 10
years old 12 years old that you're gonna
be on a show with 50 cent I would be
like you can kill me afterwards because
I don't need to live anymore
and so is he is he a big guy what does
he like he is so the first time I ever
met him so I went on for season six I
went to go film episode one and we were
doing the table read for episode 2 yeah
so I saw him come in and he's way bigger
than the table read is when everybody
gets together from the cast at all yes
correct practice the script yeah so we
did that and then I like saw him a
little bit but not much because he was
directing episode 3 so that's when he
like kind of takes over but because his
character is dead and he's now just an
executive producer on the show so he
didn't have to do much so he didn't say
much I didn't really meet him and I left
because I had a meeting right after in
New York so then I went the next day I
had to film episode 1 and I went in the
gym upstairs of the studio because we
film at Steiner Studios in Brooklyn and
there's a gym up there and I'm lifting
and I'm listening to 50 cent no word of
a lie
you don't move yeah it was it was um put
his brains out [ __ ] but he I think it
was called heat and he comes out Pacino
yeah if you listen to a movie wire in
the gym yeah go on
yeah so he walks in and he starts
lifting next to me and is he strong he
is his arms are bigger than my head like
no joke massive and yeah he's like in
like jeans like just got off like set
and yeah he's ripped so um so I'm
lifting and then
his tits look like hammocks bro for
muscle he's got to help out that guy
that just asked the question yeah there
if you want to know yeah go read that
immense muscle fitness episode with a
magazine with um he's 50 cent Curtis I
don't think he looks like that now that
was like maybe when he's like
40-something now his arms are just big I
think he's got a little little stomach
he's been relaxed and his eating [ __ ]
Twizzlers unsettled oh really yeah does
he have any children or not yeah he has
a son I think he has two sons one he
hates and one that he'll he likes that's
nice but um very [ __ ] Lannister oh
yeah so I sold he came up to me and he
was just like you film yet he like came
up to me and I was like oh [ __ ] and I
was like I was like no I'm like I'm
going down after this like it's I don't
have a call time till three and I was
like are you starting your
pre-production for directing and he's
like yeah we started doing all that and
then I saw i filmed episode 2 and I and
I actually filmed two and three
back-to-back so I stayed in New York you
spot him no I did you hold water in your
mouth for me was thirsty he did his own
thing did he got bench yes but so then
we came at breakfast and we had already
filmed one day for episode two and then
we had another day for episode three
okay so he comes up to me at breakfast
it's like 6 a.m. because I went and
lifted early and he comes up to me he's
like dude like your [ __ ] is like super
funny like I watched his stuff from
yesterday like you're hilarious and oh
that's cool [ __ ] and that was like kind
of like maybe one of the coolest moments
ever like 50 cent tells you like that
year of honey and like heat like I'm at
breakfast I'm alone and he could have
easily just walked in got his [ __ ] and
you know when it kind of seems like he
keeps coming over when you're by
yourself no but the craziest thing was
how people get molested in Hollywood
they don't know what's going on yeah
maybe yeah they're just all of a sudden
like 50 Cent's like [ __ ] man does he
have a lot of ladies around him or not
no not not when we were actually got an
email that came out and be like no one's
allowed to come on set because this is
when the whole six nine [ __ ] was
happening with like like he was getting
shot at and some a guy sends friends
with them so they're like no people
allowed on set like that aren't approved
but you know the craziest thing was um
[ __ ] I forgot what I was saying women no
oh no so so that morning I miss
Sebastian in here
like I booked him and then he came in
and I was filming so I was watching the
live yeah I was watching the live in um
in my dressing room so 50 maps out the
UM the scene that we have like what
director does he'll tell you like you
should walk here like does that feel
comfortable for you when do you say this
and you kind of work with the director
with that you know but as for the
listeners and so we do that and I I go
upstairs to go watch the live feed I had
like 20 minutes to kill and I had to
change my outfit and all of a sudden I
look on Instagram and he bought like the
first two sections of Ja Rule's of Ja
Rule's show oh yeah
and like bought those tickets so no one
would be there and then posted it on
Instagram and like cause like a major
issue like a major beef again he like
rekindled the 20 year old beef and he
just been totally chill and he just been
told Jill and then he puts his phone
down directs us like we do the scene we
get off set maybe like an hour and a
half later and he's like yeah like that
was [ __ ] awesome I got this stuff and
then he goes oh [ __ ] I just [ __ ] call
that ja Rule and forgot about it and
like went on his phone and was like oh
[ __ ] like I totally forgot I did this 50
cent buys two hundred tickets to the ja
Rule concert to keep seats empty and on
October 30th cuz I was um I always film
the episode on Halloween
you just put more money in Gerald's
pocket no one was showing up to that
show
yes an entire festival money but he is
he is a [ __ ] entrepreneur like he is
a true that guy knows what the [ __ ] is
up like every time he has something he
wants to promote something goes in the
news like he knows what he's doing it's
all strategic he's a [ __ ] genius hmm
yeah so when you're around him it seems
like what does he seem like does he seem
like a tough guy does he seem like a
businessman does he seem like a comedian
really yeah he's he's got like he's very
similar to like [ __ ] like sob and like
that kind of whole like like that
tough-guy like comedy you know anybody
it's he's very similar to that and I
know I don't want to get Brendan that's
a distraction that he's like 57
Brendan's probably definitely can hear
this wherever he is Rennie can always
hear people talking about Cody how far
away they are and the guy also asked
what it's like with Theo which I did
want to comment on there
working with you guys it is [ __ ]
hilarious which is why my laugh ruins
episodes mean it's like I and the ant
axe challenge like it's you guys are
laughing like imagine being in the room
with it like it's [ __ ] hilarious like
my laugh is annoying I get it but it's
hard because it's funny you know I mean
yeah yeah you definitely your laugh was
egregious in the beginning a lot of
people interrupt yeah that was that well
that was the first time I got a mic and
then Bo texting me that morning like hey
man got a lot of problems with a fan no
more Mike with a microphone and then I
got no joke 200 iums who's the clown in
the back huh specify it wasn't me that's
that's always what I'm losing with the
microphone yeah Jesus love the app but
that guy cats but I've gotten better a
lot of people are like ok like it's good
so I got my microphone back and no more
laugh I cover my mouth well I think
that's while this episode's good because
people can experience a little bit more
than Joey yeah
we call them joy Yanni yeah you know and
uh and yeah it's uh yeah man it actually
is really a blessing I'm glad that you
and Nick have a good rapport you know
even when I'm not around because yeah I
think if it were yeah I just I know I
couldn't keep yeah I don't even if we'd
probably still be together forever
Gianni passing through with the joy
sometimes because it's been a lot it has
been a lot of work it's been a lot of
work for Nick it's been a lot of work of
back and forth and so yeah but that's
originally why I wanted to start with
you like like I mean I'm not gonna say
I'm gonna say like I saw like so much
potential cuz I like like I think I was
like this guy is gonna be [ __ ] huge
like people just don't know about him
yeah and I'm like I want to help in any
way I can because I assumed it's like
pretty [ __ ] stressful you're on the
road like you're trying to sell tickets
you're doing a podcast so that's when I
originally came and was like I want to
help with social media stuff and like I
mean it's really dumb man and like
you've done it to an end yeah you're
right man you said I just want to help
and you know that's a good going I was
just gonna say booking is not it's the
worst like there are companies that like
people pay thousands of dollars to to
like get guests for them and stuff like
and especially if we're trying to hit a
specific day like it's not easy and I'm
super glad I don't have to
yeah yeah that's true man I don't even
know if we could have had yeah I like I
don't know I I mean I guess I don't know
if I was planning on doing I had no idea
what the plan was you know yeah when I
came in we only had Jay Mohr and a
Greyhound bus driver
Oh in that hole and the homeless guy
what about the homeless guy Oh uneven
Steve and he must not be doing well I
haven't gotten a text back with him in a
while about eight months but then we
also had some faults like if we can look
back like the the guy who had Tourette's
which we don't really know if he beats
Tourette's and then we found out later
that he was involved in a sex cult where
they all got could everybody got to read
I didn't know as an STD I think it's
going around
and in the crazy part is one day these
same people are gonna be probably maybe
sooner than later gonna be emailing you
back to book you they'll be like yeah
we'd love to have that person on can you
come on our podcast yeah which is funny
because now I do have a publicist
because you know a couple months before
the movie out and movie comes out you
want to like yeah like I go on podcast
because I want people to see the movie
you know what I mean and she helps me
with that and it's kind of interesting
because yeah that is like I was I email
other people like Bobby Lee I'm going on
Tiger belly well I would have already
have been on but yeah like before I'm
emailing like hey George can we get
Bobby on this past weekend and then it's
kind of the opposite now like hey yeah I
want to come on like tell you that yeah
that's cool man yeah and Jionni's
getting cornered by the shows he goes on
why isn't why can't I go on Theo show
twice you're at they're asking you why
aren't you on Theo show no no they're
asking me why they are not do show oh
wow well look talk to my Booker it's the
only thing I can say man that's why I
don't handle it dude bro the t even that
well the funny thing is now like even
David Spade the other day like he's like
hey man I mean I think I need some help
with this podcast thing and I'm like
that's just crazy that day in context
hey man I'd love to come back on the
podcast dude we're gonna have them me
and Dana have the same problem yes
you'll do yeah that's studio one day you
never know yeah it's like and we can
make good content and stuff that's more
fair I think you know and people can own
a part of what they do yeah this is kind
of [ __ ] that no one owns like the
stuff like you're a showrunner and you
don't have
and he say and what happens to your show
yeah I think this is mine you know I
mean like this is my people do 20 years
of development to get stuff made and
these these personalities like when they
go on networks usually they get stifled
and it's it doesn't end up being them
like David Spade could have an awesome
podcast yeah really what if he wanted to
he could be so good yeah yeah what is he
looking to do one uh yeah he's saying
like who would be a good co-host for me
to do one with you know us dude how are
we gonna do it though we'll talk affair
but like yeah yeah fortune would be dope
dude I've the other night so you know
obviously name-dropping here but I went
to met up with Spade to get some food
just have dinner and I'm walking up to
the restaurant to open the door and
Schwartz and comes running up behind me
to like scare me scared the [ __ ] out of
me dude really did he [ __ ] himself well
I did it I think that was his move yeah
diarrhea
he's like dang you were so scared I just
[ __ ] myself but but then we stood around
and talked for like two minutes and was
literally one of the funniest
conversations that I've never been
really see that see well that's the
stuff that I [ __ ] love like I when
I'm going on set with actors like it's
not that I don't get along with them
because I do like I met Cory but I feel
like out of place because they're like
very like like PC and it's like you have
to do this and I trained at Juilliard
and that's not the way I am like I
[ __ ] chill with you and like you know
like when I went to the comedy store
that night Bobby Lee and Chris D'Elia
and Sebastian or all standing around
like that's like I'm not saying like
that's like who I think I am but like
that's like the crew that I like feel
like a part of like and then I go on set
with other people who are like actors
and they're just like they're kind of
like off-putting almost yeah you don't
take it as seriously you know me you
take it seriously you know work but you
don't take it as seriously in your ego
and that's something Nick said earlier
actors are like empty vessels almost
like they're told like be here say this
do this and I feel like it bleeds into
it like most of them that's why you can
go have see actors on this show I don't
find him as interesting generally yeah I
don't have a ton of life experience like
yeah stuff but Jionni was a hockey
player sure dude Johnny was a hockey
player
I mean look Jionni could be the hottest
twink in this [ __ ] City you don't see
a twink pound-for-pound as uh you know
and a twink is a sort of a lien what is
a twink Johnny um it's more like a young
hairless kind of like a little skinnier
boyish gay male yeah yeah that all the
older game in one yeah and then run yeah
they hire me like carry muffins around
unfold drapes and stuff my mom actually
was like why does why is everyone
commenting on your Instagram you know
get that hit a twink she's like why are
people and why is everyone calling you
at the swing say a boy and I'm like
[ __ ] has to do with a mullet
okay yeah want to I'm gonna just be
grateful to be in Hollywood a little
hairless and great thank you very much
Nick for putting up with everything and
for getting us this far thank you Gianni
thank you special to be a part of this
like it really is like I love being here
and we have a great time
yeah well I'm excited to see where your
career goes man and I'm like I just hope
that we don't lose our Booker
yeah but for real though everyone um so
the movie will be coming out tomorrow
when this airs on Thursday May 30th the
movie comes out Friday May 31st please
go see it you're gonna love it it's
[ __ ] awesome and let me know what you
think yeah let him know what you think
now there's a great opportunity for you
to have you know to let Jionni know what
you think about that movie and it's
called mas torn Octavia Spencer so
talented she was in the help man and
she's incredible so good and it's so
weird because you go on set with an
awful like she's a prime example of
someone that I did gel with because
she's not a typical act actress you know
what I mean like she is an oscar-winning
actress and then you get on set and
she's crazy and she's funny and she's
doing accents and she's like like
putting on wigs and stuff like that
she's hilarious she who yeah so that's
what I was super nervous about going
into I was like I'll [ __ ] like I have to
do a scene with her where she [ __ ]
pulls a gun on me like are you [ __ ]
me scary but then you go on set and she
makes you feel comfortable it's great
there you go go see MA Johnny thank you
for being here and thank you for
everything you do for this past weekend
and uh and I'll talk to you guys soon
[Music]
on the breeze and I feel I'm full and
like these leaves I must be I'll share
this piece of thought it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]